or aux états unis près de siècle
l'activité du volcan le mont
saint-helens intensifiée on a déjà
recensé de petites secousses les
touristes sont tenus à distance
françois julliard une fumée inquiétante
des cendres projetées à 3000 m
d'altitude le mont sainte hélène sort de
sa torpeur
depuis deux jours les sismographes
s'affolent des secousses ont été
détectés sur le mont la pression
augmente dangereusement dans le volcan
nous avons élevé le seuil d alerte au
niveau 3
ce qui signifie qu'une éruption
contenant du magma est imminente selon
les géologues imminente cela signifie
dans les prochaines 24 heures nous vous
demandons de vous diriger vers vos
voitures sans courir musée prudemment et
doucement les deux mille touristes qui
assistaient au spectacle sont évacuées
dans la bonne humeur
on est surtout déçus et repartons plus
quelle serait la peur non elle voudrait
rester pour regarder pas de panique
et pourtant le 18 mai 1981 suite à une
violente explosion la montagne de feu
comme l'appelaient les indiens tué 57
personnes